[Music]
Paranormal Activity oh yeah I saw it
okay so the buzzin hype surrounding this
movies becomes some sort of supernatural
life force all on its own
it's been called like the scariest movie
ever period and I actually think it just
reached this quota for a million
requests ago nationwide so expect this
movie to come to a movie theater near
you pretty soon oh and when you see this
movie go see it with a girl because
every girl in the auditorium looked like
this so I'm a big documentary style take
your camera and go finally goes john
rowe fan if that's actually a genre I
watch sightings every Friday in the 90s
Sally the little ghost girl scared the
out of me
i watch Ghost Hunters all the time so
this movie they have to do a pretty good
job at sucking me in and making me
forget that it's fictional not an easy
thing to do with me so how did it do
they don't get scared or jump in movies
apparently however I will sit there
perfectly statuesque and have the right
side of my body break out in the cold
goosebumps yeah that actually happened
this movie does a good job at bringing
you into it and having you experience it
as a more realistic experience due to it
being film like it's this guy's footage
kind of like Blair Witch say what you
want about Blair Witch but apparently
they were 10 years ahead of a curb if
for nothing else being this successful
on the budget of about 8 bucks is the
ultimate slap in the face to any monster
budget disappointment of the past decade
no big special effects nothing like the
CGI ground opening up in CGI hands
grabbing someone and breaking them down
to the CGI brimstone in CGI hell no
simple camera angles with simple yet
hard to explain effects psychological
anxiety with frightening and haunting
ambient noise in the middle of the night
it is ultimately everything you were
afraid of as a kid if you ever had a
nightlight as a kid this movie is
comprised of all the reasons as to why
there are a few moments where this
fictional footage seems so real and so
chilling one huge thing I love does this
movie does not go for the cheap scares
it doesn't do what most scary movies do
and make you jump by abruptly throwing
something on the screen and then leaving
it alone kind of like
hey what's up I brought the beer and
that's somehow supposed to be the scary
moment no not in this movie jumping to
that is just reflex it does not
stick with you and it is not fear
paranormal activity totally different
cup of tea this movie is all about the
build-up of fear it's all about the
constant swell of just unease and fear
that they never fully let you feel
released from the movie brings you up to
a level of goosebumps and anxiety and
then just hold you there it's probably
not healthy for you to be in that state
for that long but it does make for some
truly chilling and the movie does
give you those moments a bang jump you
know but it's not the fulfillment you've
been waiting for because you know the
problem is still there this demon is
still staring right at them in that room
as they're talking about what they just
heard and you know this this movie
ultimately creates an environment in
which your own imagination is the
causing your own fear and in that even
after the movie ends and you leave the
movie theater don't think it's over
because it's not over the Encore of this
movie going experience comes that night
when you're at home and you try to get
what's usually categorized as a good
night's sleep and when you're laying in
bed waiting to go to sleep
you realize that you just watched a
movie about a demon terrorizing two
people who are in the exact same place
you're in now in the bedroom in bed with
the lights off yeah that's brilliant
film production this movie effectively
strips that secure feeling you're
supposed to feel when you're in the
sanctity of your own bed if this movie
teaches you anything is that your
bedroom is the least secure place in
your entire house and don't think having
someone in your bed will help you
because it didn't for them so you just
lay in bed thinking about the most
chilling parts of this movie or you
think about what demonic sounds will
sound like in your house and then you
think about what it would feel like if
your covers were pulled off not saying
I've done that I'm just saying I can
think of about three parts in particular
that I cannot shake from my head and a
movie that makes you feel this
vulnerable comes along once in a long
while from my experience anyway it's an
experience that genuinely sticks with
you so go watch it and let me know what
you think it write me tell me your
ghost stories I want to hear
you
[Music]